so is that one song that gets you up out
of your chair I want to know what that
one song is weird I don't know these for
the percolator it's tough on a
circulator it's time for the percolator
yeah oh yeah yeah you know what know
what to do for me what is it we do uncle
Luke big booty ho top witty uncle Luke
Scott that is to get you out your chair
shake your booty you're gonna lose five
pounds
the Fiesta remix our chili and Jesus I
didn't think you were going to go our
Kelly on me it takes to rob bass yeah
and you hear that deal like um I want to
write right now I'm not make that I came
to get down I've never seen better drunk
acting in my entire life I think it's
probably one of the hardest things to
act man that's really just taking it
back satellite with you mister voice and
muscle memory with your favorites broke
out here so running man I'm like at the
wat I like I like can you explain to me
white girl wasted
there's no inhibitions what so ever
could have anything solid tore down
don't go nowhere wipe your way you can
like throw away white girls no a white
girl wasted
what you're talking about that's the key
not to even remember Sen or held guilt
the ultimate fun and kids break in and
next is like cancel cancel cancel cancel
never have to call in her name upon all
have menthol in the name of fun if women
are wilder than men yes I have no
question not only Barnett Adler is live
in a wild is and a go see the movie and
that will remove all down
[Music]
[Music]